[Music]
this week on book notes our guest is
larone bennett executive editor of ebony
magazine
he joins us to discuss his recent book
forced into glory abraham lincoln's
white dream
[Music]
larone bennett jr
where did you get the title of your book
forced in the glory
i thought that book
captured the essence of what i was
trying to say in the sense
that
lincoln from my standpoint
was driven was forced
into a glory that he
resisted i think every step of the way
uh uh adam growowski one of the
of his great critics during the civil
war here in washington
uh wrote a a paragraph which said that
he was literally whipped
into glory i i i thought maybe force
would be a better term for the cover and
so i settled on forced into glory
and this again captures my idea
and one of the basic ideas of the book
is that there were all these
extraordinary
men and women
many of them white
in washington
in 1862 and 63.
the american people generally do not
know anything about any of them
uh
ashley lyman trumbull
zechariah chandler salman chase
all these people i say and i try to
detail it for
650 pages or so
really
pushed lincoln to glory and i my my the
pen i put into it lincoln himself said
i was driven to it
literally driven to it
your sub
title on the book is abraham lincoln's
white dream what's that mean
it means that
contrary to what most people think
abraham lincoln's deepest desire
was to deport
all black people
and create
an all-white nation
it sounds like a wild idea now and it is
a wild idea
but from about 1852 until his death
he worked
feverishly to try to
create deportation plans colonization
plans
uh to send black people either to africa
or to south africa south america or to
the islands of the sea uh no most people
and you know the story
one of his greatest utterances
people quote it all the time uh uh
copeland's great thing
we cannot escape we cannot escape
history the last best hope of the world
he said these words in a state of the
union message on december the first 1862
in which he asked congress to pass three
constitutional amendments
one to buy the slaves
second to to declare free all people who
had actually escaped but the third one
his proposed 15th amendment
asked congress
to allocate money
to deport black people to another place
now it's most
i think it's
probably other than the second inaugural
the the we cannot escape history
ending there is just just just
portrait everybody knows nobody talks
about the fact that what he was asking
congress to do was to deport black
people it was one of his deepest ideas
and i make the point also and and and
almost everything i say in here i take
from lincoln are from documents of the
time
it was not just something he wanted to
push
black people out
he had an idea of of this great giant
vacuum sound black people leaving and
white people from all over the world
coming here and creating this all-white
nation as a matter of fact i say as you
know
in his i have a dream speech
at alton illinois
in in 1858
he called for
a haven a white haven for free white
people everywhere the world over now
these are lincoln's work and the
interesting thing about that is that he
underlined these four words free white
people everywhere he underlined him
this was his i have a dream speech
he was passionately committed to
to to deporting black people and
creating a white nation let me say an
extenuation
uh
he believed that that was the only way
to solve the race problem i i found that
offensive and and strange but he
believed that that was the only way to
solve the race race problem he said over
and over again he did not believe that
black people and white people could live
together inequality in the united states
of america did you ever think
differently about abraham lincoln
no really and i try to explain in the
beginning of the book first sentence in
the book
first sentence in the book says
i was a child in
white as mississippi reading for my life
when i discovered for the first time
that everything i'd been taught about
abraham lincoln was a lie
now i imagine i was 10 11 somewhere
there
uh before then apparently i'd believe
that this this great uh
this was a great emancipator what
happened actually when i was 10 11 and i
ought to explain
i was one of these strange children
i read everything i could put my hand on
any any book any piece of paper anything
i could find
i read and so
for some strange reason in mississippi
uh
in the 30s
i happened to see abraham lincoln's
address at charleston illinois
on september 18th 1858 the lincoln
douglas debate in the lincoln douglas
debate
and i read it and and i was just just
absolutely shocked
and from that point on i started to
researching lincoln and trying to find
out everything i could about him i
wasn't trying to get a degree i wasn't
trying to pass the course as i say in
the book i was trying to save my life
because i find it difficult to
understand
how people could say this man was the
greatest apostle of brotherhood in the
united states of america you say on page
114 not only is lincoln a church
he is also an industry precisely
precisely
and
the key
are
one of the keys to the american
personality but an industry yes
all over the country
now people are engaged in
packaging information on on lincoln
putting together exhibits on lincoln
doing this and doing that about lincoln
it's a whole industry that that that
employs
hundreds of people probably thousands of
people
and it's important from that way he's
also a religion
uh and as i indicate in that same
chapter barbara patrick i think her name
is
said in in the new york times
before this book was published that that
lincoln is such a god that the ordinary
rules of evidence don't apply to him
uh
and and and also
the third point i think is important
he is
one of the keys
to america
americans
see themselves in lincoln american
politicians
tend to measure themselves about lincoln
he is a secular saint
and i know that and i know
and i said that that what i'm proposing
here that we look at lincoln
is painful painful to whites and to
blacks but i think it's necessary
for the health of this country and for
what we've got to do
about
completing the task we started in the
civil war but never finished have you
ever been invited to speak to the
abraham lincoln association or the
lincoln forum
neither
no i have not
uh i've talked to a number of group
groups
across the country but i've not been
invited by those two groups
um
i have
been honored by some lincoln
associations before this came out but uh
no i've not been invited to speak to
them and one of the suggestions i make
in this book
i feel strongly about it that that there
ought to be a dialogue
between academic people the lincoln
establishment as i say
and and
and and and other people who have a
different vision
of lincoln
uh
to back up and to get into some i
this book has been
attacked pretty harshly
in some quarters praised
enthusiastically and others but
i am not
up to this date and and late summer
early fall
i've not seen a single review which
disagrees with any one of my four major
points the fifth point that i disagree
with i've not seen a degree a uh
uh uh a review
anywhere which disagrees with my
four or five major points and if i
possibly can make them my my first point
is that the emancipation proclamation
did not free black people
and it's doubtful
if it ever freed anybody anywhere
and that abraham lincoln
was not
the great emancipator
of the small emancipated other
medium-sized emancipator that's the
first point can i stop and ask did you
say that
in fact
the emancipation proclamation may have
created another half million slaves as
ever right
thank you thank you
not only did it not free anybody
it enslaved a re-enslave more
slaves than it ever freed because
lincoln said in the document which most
people will never read
he said that he was specifically
excluding
certain slaves in southern illinois
southern louisiana and eastern virginia
and elsewhere but these were the two
main
categories
now why did he exclude these slaves in
louisiana because they were the only
slaves he could have freed on january
the first 1863
the union controls southern
uh louisiana and new orleans the union
controlled eastern virginia now on
january first he could have freed these
slaves all he had to do was just not
specifically exclude them
instead of freeing them abraham lincoln
unfortunately on january 1st said
i'm not talking about you
this document you were in the same as
you were as though this document never
existed so we have about a hundred
thousand slaves in southern illinois
southern louisiana sorry about that and
80 000 or so in eastern virginia
having some 275 000 slaves in in
tennessee who were not touched by it
all across the south i give an estimate
of approximately 500 000 slaves
who were re-enslaved or kept in slavery
by the emancipation proclamation
i want to come back to that and then as
i make my second point
and i want to tell you what those
critics say in response to this is the
second point said abraham lincoln was a
racist
i i don't have any joy in making that
but i think truth is important
he who said
who used the n word habitually
who loved donkey jokes and and and
blackface shows
who said in illinois and elsewhere that
he was opposed to black people voting
sitting on jurors in a marine with white
people and holding office
two lincoln was a racist three
abraham lincoln wanted to deport black
people
and create an all-white nation that's
three
four
abraham lincoln
was
and and this is the controversial point
maybe there were not five four that
abraham lincoln was
contrary to what all the historians say
of an equivocating vacillating
leader
who
the war
delayed emancipation
and increase the number of casualties
now
there's no agreement on that but the
other three points are four points
all my critics agree on what they say
and i'll be very brief about this
they say
larone bennett
said
that the emancipation proclamation
didn't free black people
and he's a terrible man for disturbing
the peace of the republic that's the
first sentence the second sentence
of course the emancipation proclamation
didn't free black people the 13th
amendment everybody knows that freed
black people they agree with my first
point the second point
they say lauren bennett this is a review
says that abraham lincoln was a racist
and he's a terrible man
for saying that
of course he was a racist second
sentence
all white people in the 19th century
were racist i disagree with that and i i
i defend white people in 19th century i
think it's absurd to say that everybody
in the 19th century was a racist but
that's their defense my point is they
agree with my second point they say of
course he was a racist
the third point again is uh
jerome bennett says that abraham lincoln
wanted to deport
black people and create a white nation
sail of course he wanted to deport black
people
not
because he disliked them but because he
loved them so much
and he didn't think they'd ever be
treated right in america my point is
in late
summer
early fall is that
all of the critics i've seen
agree with my basic points i don't know
a reputable historian with a library
card anywhere who maintains that the
emancipation proclamation freed black
people i don't believe one exists
anywhere
and yet i'm i'm they people are
screaming and hollering why did you say
this it's the truth
you were
born where
in
mississippi i was born
in clarksdale my mother was visiting
there we were
i grew up in jackson and i grew up in
jackson mississippi what did your dad do
my dad was a chauffeur
uh and my mother was a cook she was a
chef cook in a restaurant
there were uh
two of us in the family and my sister
and i and we grew we grew up in uh in in
mississippi uh uh
during the thirties and and forties when
did you leave
in 45 i left to go to college
i left to go to uh
atlanta to a morehouse college uh where
i
uh finished in 1949 and
started working in atlanta for four five
years on the atlanta daily world and
then i went to atlanta to chicago to
ebony magazine where you still are
a writer still a writer yeah at ebony i
am still at ebony yes
i
worked as associate editor and
senior editor and now
i'm executive editor when you were at
morehouse college what were they telling
you about abraham lincoln
and that's an all-black college it's an
all-black college
two things it's very interesting very
interesting
the most enlightened enlightened
professors
said of course he didn't free the slaves
uh
of course he was a racist
some orthodox professors said
well they were extenuating circumstances
and and uh these black professors some
some black professors they were
extenuating circumstances
the major point is
the point i make in this book
is people
in black institution didn't talk about
abraham lincoln that much
uh and as i said about one interesting
point
and somebody needs to do a long essay on
it if somebody does not i'll do it
if i'm still here
white
authors have written about 16 000 books
and monographs
on abraham lincoln
black authors have written in the last
135 years
maybe two or three maybe four
this is probably
possibly
the first full-scale reassessment and
study of abraham lincoln but
in the last 135 years
black authors have paid very little
attention to abraham lincoln three or
four books maybe five
compared to sixteen thousand books and
monographs
uh a basilar and i quote him in my book
basta had an essay in 1935 roy basler
roy basler he he was he was astonished
by that he said you know why black
intellectuals don't don't don't don't
don't deal with lincoln moore and they
said perhaps they've not found
a sign to to to to to emancipate them by
uh to uh to move uh to follow at any
rate
the interesting thing is that in
predominantly black institutions
in black circles
apart from
few pieces of poetry here and there
abraham lincoln has never been the thing
in black america
that he's always been in white america
which suggests to me and this is
speculation but i say it in the book
i surmise
that black people know lincoln have
always known him
at a depth beneath words
at any rate they have not felt that
necessary they've not felt the need or
the interest to address them the way
white historians have addressed it if
you'd had the opportunity what would you
have said to martin luther king when he
was standing on the steps of the lincoln
memorial
giving his i have a dream speech in
1963.
i would said
that
you're absolutely right
when you said that he issued a check
and it came back insufficient funds
because the emancipation proclamation
was precisely that
i always said you're absolutely right
to say
that the real
test now is to
get together and write the emancipation
that lincoln didn't write because as i
say in this book
martin luther king jr had a healthy
dose of skepticism about what abraham
lincoln meant and what abraham lincoln
said and in his book uh where do we go
from here i think
he he details most of the things i say
in here but says at the end
that will extenuating circumstances he
believes he can detect some growth in
lincoln i have problems with the growth
but we are together on the analysis he
was a racist and king knew it king said
it
and
fundamentally i agree with most of his
analysis now if you just let me put one
pin in this
this is painful i've said it and i i
keep saying it over not only the white
people
i don't live white people
for for the last 135 years
every medium of communication
outside the medium media recontroller
said lincoln was the great savior the
greatest liberator he freed you on
january the first out of the goodness of
of his heart and so
large numbers of black people have just
worshiped lincoln i mean he's
because they believe that he did what
people say he did
and it's painful
to say
to them and to my community and other
communities he didn't do it he didn't
want to do it he was completely
different man the point i'm coming to
finally
if you you let me go through this
scenario
on january the first
a thursday
1863
here in washington
slightly after 12 o'clock
they had the new year's reception in the
morning
and slightly after 12 o'clock
secretary sued and his son
took the
document the emancipation proclamation
to to lincoln in the cabinet room i
think it was and
and and
i don't know let me tell you
lincoln
lincoln took a steel tip pin
and and he he took the pen and he moved
to the line where he was supposed to
sign and all of a sudden when he got to
this line lincoln tells the story when
he got to this line his hand started
shaking so violently
that he couldn't sign it and he and he
dropped the pin and he thought
what's going on here
so he took the pen again
still to a pen and he moved it to the
place
and he started to sign in his hands
start shaking so violently
that that that he couldn't say he
dropped it again
and lincoln was very superstitious
and
he stopped in awe
and then he said
abraham lincoln is talking then he said
a very simple explanation came to me
i had been signing
order i mean i've been shaking hands all
that morning at the new year's res
reception
and my arm was virtually paralyzed hence
he said a very simple explanation for
this
phenomenon i think the explanation is
too simple but uh that's what he said at
any rate he finally was able to sign the
document now
my point
the poetry
the songs
the scholars
the major newspapers
the major museum people
tell us that at that moment
choirs start to sing over the
alleghenies and over
stone mountain and georgia and black
people start saying free at last free at
last
thank god almighty i'm free at last
that's pretty it hurts me
to say it's not true
hurts me not to say it's not true but
but but but
any slave
in georgia
who said free at last surrounded by
confederate troops on january 1st 1863
was immediately sent to heaven
any slave in alabama who said that so
i'm trying to say that
that that
this poetry i wish it were true
it is not true
virtually almost everything we've been
told about abraham lincoln in the last
135 years
is wrong on each correcting
uh needs somebody to have a long
dialogue on when you hear that they're
trying to raise about 125 million
dollars to buy
or to build a library to abraham lincoln
in springfield illinois what's your
reaction
i think we need an equal amount of money
more money in fact
let me let me back up
i think we need to to research lincoln's
life i think we need to know everything
we can about him my book complains that
that people don't know anything about
lincoln even 135 years later
i think we need to know that i think
also
we need an equal amount of money we need
more money
dedicated
to the task
of studying the real emancipators
a studying charles sumner
and that is stevens
and wendell phillips
oh white men all white men all white men
they tell me all everybody was a
craziest then
these men were a hundred years ahead of
abraham lincoln in terms of their
understanding of democracy
and racial equality in this country
now one of the one of my complaints in
that book
is that
i'm coming back to blackmail white
americans why do i know few if any white
americans know who lyman trummer was
who was he
lyman trummel was a senator from
illinois
in lincoln's time
he had the traditional problems of many
of the white men are there of the time
but he is far more advanced in his
understanding of what liberty required
of him he opposed the future to slave
act in illinois at a time when abraham
lincoln was was back in the hunting of
men women and children
he defeated
abraham lincoln for the senate and the
reason he defeated lincoln for the
senate is because lincoln was too
conservative
on the issue of slavery
in illinois and in america but the
bottom line
lyman trummel came to washington
he was the author
of the first confiscation act
which began the emancipation
proclamation in august 1861
he was the author of the second
conversation act which was the most
sweeping act of emancipation
passed by congress uh are enacted during
lincoln stein more sweeping than the
emancipation proclamation
and he was one of the principal authors
of the 13th amendment
a hundred years ahead of lincoln nobody
in illinois knows lyme and trouble and
i'm that i'm exaggerating one or two
people knowing but they've we've had no
major exhibits
in in illinois online and trauma we had
a hundred exhibits on lincoln who didn't
believe in equality who did little or
nothing to advance the abolitionist
process
why
isn't
the culture structure
teaching people lyman trumbull's name
arwen de phillips are charles sumner as
you know almost every poll that's ever
taken has abraham lincoln is number one
as you know because you write about in
your book and you don't put this
qualifier on it but
a lot of liberal american college
professors
think lincoln was the greatest why
white college professor white qualifier
and and almost all of the major
history professors in this country
and i i find that i find that
extraordinary because because
until
the capture of atlanta
and the nomination of general mcclellan
on the democratic ticket laid in 1864
until late 1864 almost all members of
lincoln's party thought he was a
disaster as a president
and uh most of them were looking for
some alternative candidate
almost all members of
the washington
power structure at that time
said he lacked will he liked the
resolution he liked vision
and that he was prolonging the war by
his inadequacies a lyman trumbull said
he'd like the resolution needed in this
great test his secretary i mean his
attorney general bates said he liked
will
uh uh others said in at the time
that he was simply a terrible leader
and yet
135 years later
almost all the scholars say it was the
greatest
leader we've ever had
in our country perhaps in in the world
why
because
they have not read the record i i say
uh
because that has been
for 135 years
one of the biggest attempts in all
history
to hide a man and a history
and to make the man entirely different
from
what
he
was and and and
why
because lincoln is a mask
for certain deep-seated problems
we blacks and whites
have resisted and refused to deal with
particularly the problem of slavery
the problem of
emancipation and and and the problem of
black freedom in this country
lincoln
far from being a leader
let that mean
stop and deal with it lincoln far from
being a leader
was
everybody knows him everybody
he was
a man on defense
who denounced the extremists on both
sides who talked out of both sides of
his mouth
and
this is an ideal that that that that
appeals to to many people
i say in the book
that although people won't tell us who
lincoln was history knows
lincoln
they know
that he was a wafflin equivocating
person i quoted a person in one of the
major papers just before the book was
published they said who said that
george bush and other presidential
candidates reminded them of lincoln why
did they remind
this columnist of lincoln because he
waffled because he talked out of both
sides of his mouth in different
audiences history knows abraham lincoln
and i it's my suggestion that
many
scholars are defending that image of
leadership what's the isolated quote
school
the isolated quote school is the the the
tendency of major
lincoln biographers
to quote take isolated quotes out of
context
and use them without giving us the
context or the setting of the man for
example they they tell us
and i won't name the the historian whom
i
admire and respect on other grounds said
that the
december the 1862
state of the union message we talked
about the last best hope of the earth
was one of the greatest
statements
in the history of the world
he does not tell us
that lincoln was asking congress to
deport black people
so we get in the peoria speech
lincoln says you know i love the
declaration of independence
one of the great documents of all time
one paragraph two paragraphs later he
said i don't want you to misunderstand
me he's talking to ten or twelve
thousand
white people in the law don't you
understand me i'm not talking about
equality i'm not talking about making
black people equal i'm not talking about
freeing black people in the south but
it's a great document in the abstract
you get this and i i took a whole
chapter because i knew i would have to
do that
i took a whole chapter and detail
the defenses that scholars built into
that work
you you talk about benjamin thomas
and i know i've done so many shows here
on abraham lincoln that more often than
not a
author will say it's the single
best volume best one volume biography
of abraham lincoln number one why did
they say that who was he
and why did you spend a lot of time
writing about him
thomas's one volume work
is readable
came at a time when
people were groping for some new way
to to deal with lincoln if if memory
serves i think it came out sometime
around 52 or something sometime around
that
uh
and and
it was just immediately elevated to
um the best one-volume treatment of
lincoln available
i used it as an example
and i went down a list of all the things
that that that
thomas did not tell us let me read them
so it'll be easier for you you say
lincoln doesn't tell us that lincoln
thomas doesn't tell us that lincoln used
the n-word he doesn't tell us that
lincoln loved n jokes he doesn't tell us
that lincoln voted for jim crow
legislation in the illinois legislature
he doesn't tell us that lincoln said
there was a natural disgust in the minds
of nearly all white people about black
and white sex he doesn't tell us that
lincoln's support of the illinois black
laws he doesn't tell us that president
lincoln personally ordered union
officers to return runaway slaves to
slave masters he doesn't tell us that
president clinton tried for quote nearly
a year and a half in his own words to
save slavery in the united states
all these things i i say and and
this is typical
of major biographies on lincoln
in the last 135 years
that the the famous charleston quote is
is is the stumbling block
as i say in the book
the best
biographers
will summarize the charleston quote
and uh and what is that and what was the
reason for it uh in the charleston quote
on
saturday
september 18th 1858 lincoln said
to about 10 or 15 000 white people in
the lincoln douglas debate that
i will say then that i'm not now now
have i ever been
in favor of bringing about in any way
the social and political equality of the
white and black race that i'm not now i
ever have been in favor making voters of
of uh negroes uh jurors of negroes now
of qualifying them to hold office not to
intimate with white people and he goes
on and on a full quote and he ends by
saying that he's in favor of white
supremacy now this this is a terrible
quote
and it's a sort of
tests for lincoln biographers
the best ones will summarize the quote
and we'll make an excuse for him uh the
one of the major excuse as you know
from thomas and others is to say that
douglas was pushing him
and he had to say that to get elected
uh
other other people say
well he had to say that in order to get
elected in 1858
but most
biographers do not give the full quote
they certainly don't give it in context
and they certainly do not as thomas does
not
tell us
that lincoln voted for jim crow laws in
the illinois legislature
voted for a white school system
in illinois as a legislator
said on the platform that he supported
the black laws
and lived in illinois and never said a
word
about
an illinois law that made it a crime for
black people to live in illinois we
don't get any of this in the traditional
biographies
and my problem is
beyond lincoln
i raise the question and
it's a question of dialogue
i was raised the question of scholarship
i i say you can't divorce a man
from a setting like that
and write a biography on him i say if
you don't tell us
about the jim crow laws he supported
and the fact that he supported the
hunting of men women and children the
future to slave law
if you don't tell us these things
i think we have to reevaluate what we're
doing in scholarship
well i mentioned earlier the abraham
lincoln association which meets in
springfield the lincoln forum which
meets up in gettysburg every year
has speakers and they've never invited
you to speak if they did
would you walk into that group and give
the same thesis that you do in your book
i would walk in that group and give the
same thesis
with one exception
an exception i don't believe in lynching
parties
and if they want to arrange 15
people on a platform and they say now
you speak and now these 15 people are
going to lent you
i don't believe in that but if they want
me to make a speech
i'll make it but one scholar one vote
the way they generally do it and that's
another one of the techniques they will
ask
there's 15 20 people
to come in
and you speak and then 15 to 20 people
will speak
i will speak one scholar one vote
i would be
be delighted to to to speak
and uh i i think
we need this kind of dialogue but but
but
again back to a small problem here
i i did and and you know
i've been this road before in february
of 1968
i wrote a small essay in ebony
called was abraham lincoln a white
supremacist
just just
explosions everywhere people said the
republic is in danger i mean that just
it's murse worse than this time okay
then
people say well you know
he makes some good points we ought to
reevaluate lincoln and that number of
people
said that but the re-evaluation
did not come
that essay has been out there for some
32 years
no real response to it one of the ways
the the academic authorities respond to
me
is they put it as one of the major books
on
676
page in the footnotes
and not in the book not deal with
lincoln and racism but they're saying
the footnotes all the wrong bennetts say
this wear it on small small type and
then they will go on
we still haven't had a dialogue on this
in the country i
without being provocative
i think
it's important to the truth of white
people and black people
for us to know
what
was done and was not done
and to certainly know about the black
and white men men and women who tried to
emancipate all of us if stephen a
douglas was elected president in 1860
what do you think would have happened
unlike what
happened with abraham lincoln getting
elected
four black people
the first first case and i'm gonna ask
you ask answer your question
i i think the abolitionists had driven
the soft mat and they were not going to
take stephen douglas but that's my first
question first answer the second one if
they had
i think he would have tried
to create
a compromise
extending the modifying
his earlier compromise and i don't think
it would have would have worked i think
it had gone beyond that point at that
time
and i don't think that was any solution
uh
that the southerners would have approved
of i say in my book and i i i believe
it's true
when the phillips said it first
that
fugitive slaves and abolitionists
and the threat of insurrections
had driven southerners mad
that they in essence they committed
suicide
lincoln and his inaugural address
said
that he would have personally backed a
13th amendment which had already been
passed
which would have guaranteed slavery
forever
in the united states of america
the south refused to accept it
another question in that area and i
appreciate your question
i i i i dear i ask myself the question
lincoln was a compromise candidate again
going back to leadership he was not
elected because he was a flame and
anti-slaver advocate he was out he's
elected because he was less of a
anti-slavery advocate than seward and
and salmon chase
the question is what would have would
have happened if suet and and and chase
had been elected
president
my view is
that emancipation would have come sooner
and in a better
context
than it did under abraham lincoln on the
both of them i think you would have
pretty much the same thing i think they
would have been withdrawals
but i don't think
chase and suet
would have gone so far in a piece in the
south and the border states
and i think this comes to my material
leadership
which is real
if
lincoln had not spent two years of peas
in kentucky
if he had
mobilized 400 000 black soldiers
and issued
some emancipation order
given the soldiers freedom
i think the civil war would have been
over
two years three years at most
and i will say again on this leadership
issue and then i'm through with it
i don't understand the historians who
say his great leadership if
franklin delano roosevelt
had conducted world war ii
as disastrously
as abraham lincoln conducted the civil
war in the first two years
america would be a german protectorate
today
how many years have you been in chicago
oh about 47.
how big is ebony magazine
biggest black magazine in the world
about 2 million
subscribers about 10 million readers
overall every month
and this book was published by johnson
publishing right john johnson yes
did you try to get it published anywhere
else
no i did not
does johnson publish books all the time
no he publishes books by authors
internal books by authors primarily we
publish
several books outside but primarily
books by authors people who work at
johnson publishing company who have
worked at johnson publishing government
has your book been reviewed by the
washington post to the new york times of
the wall street journal
it has not
to this date been reviewed by
the washington post the new york times
or some other journals we can name
it has been reviewed by a number of
major
journals in this country and uh
and
as received as i say i think
enthusiastic reviews uh
from radio people and television people
when did you first think about doing a
book
about
my
it's a disagreement in my family about
that i say seven years my wife says i've
been doing it for 10 or 12 years we'll
split on 10 years maybe what i started
to do
as i mentioned i did the essay
uh in february 1968
and and and
it it was not being circulated anywhere
young historian called me from the
university of illinois and urbana say i
i can't find this in anywhere it's not
in the index
so
based on the fact that it was not being
circulated i said you know 10 or 12
years ago seven years ago i think i'll
create a book of essays and put the
lincoln essays in it i have another of
other essays that i want to put in it
well as i worked on it i said well you
know as an author says maybe you know it
needs a little update
a year or two later
three or four hundred pages i say well
it has to be a book
and so it evolved into that and
let's say ten years maybe seven or
twelve years but i've been working on it
that time and and and i say
and and and i hope you let me say
immodestly again yes i i worked on this
book
nights and weekends
for 10 years or so
after my day job i didn't i just
couldn't do this with my dj i worked 14
hours or so
at my day job and then i would go home
and i'd work at night
and then i'd work all weekend uh people
thought i was crazy and uh but i i just
i just did it
year after year
and i i i did not receive i had no
graduate assistance
books like these uh uh generally done
with an army of graduate assistants i
had no graduate assistants
and uh i didn't get in i didn't get a
grant from from a foundation i did a 10
10 years on my own and
people
you know feel sorry for you and people
of course say you're crazy
but it's one of the most
exciting 10 years i've spent because
what i had to do
is to
i had to learn how to see again
i had to create new concepts
for trying to understand lincoln because
the dominant concepts
would have led me into error
so all this time i was involved in
trying to see again learning how to see
again
and then creating new concepts for
containing a phenomenon that i think we
need a new perspective on how many
copies did you
print
i don't i don't i don't i don't remember
i know we're in the second printing but
i don't i don't remember is it like
thirty thousand versions no it wasn't
that many times no no
what's been the reaction
among black people to this
the reaction has been tremendous
it's 650 pages
footnotes it's not the kind of book you
expect people walk down the streets
reading
but i walk down the streets and and and
like people say thank you for doing the
book
thank you for this
and i've gotten
more response on this book in the black
community i've ever gotten and i have
another book uh before the mayflower
which is
one of the widest circulated black
history books ever but uh
the response to this has been electric
and i've been
very humbled by it now this is a bit
convoluted let me try to walk through
this
if white people
both you know you hear both republicans
and democrats liberals and conservatives
putting their arms around abraham
lincoln
if they think he did a good thing
and they are supporting him because they
think he freed the slaves
what advantage is it to this discussion
if in the end you're successful
in pulling the rug out from under that
all right i'm asking that question the
number ways and it's a good question i
appreciate it
um
the first the first my first response
without getting up on a high horse
but my first response always is
that i think
the truth is its own defense
is absolutely necessary my second
response is
to whites and blacks
is this warm confident
symbol who gives out freedom on the
january 1st
1863.
my second response is that that that
that you can't lie your way to freedom
you can't allow your way to freedom you
can't do it you can't lie your way
to a rainbow nation
my third response and i said in the book
people who say that are too late
i won't name a presidential candidate
anybody's name
but but the people who say that in
general know who abraham lincoln is
they know he was not john brown
they know he was not wendell phillips
they know he was not
a major advocate of liberation they know
in general what this is what most people
know about lincoln that they he did it
reluctantly he did it to save the union
that's that's that's the lincoln that
that these people worship
what is that saying that you don't fight
for freedom
if it causes problems
they know
the lincoln
they're worshiping
they don't want to know john brown
they don't want to know when to philip
they don't even want to know lyman
trumbull
and i'm saying
that that
we ought to teach
young white children won the phillips
name
who said and and uh
94 years before king
133 years before mandela
that
he wanted to create a rainbow nation
composed
of the learned and the ignorant the old
and the young the black and the white
pagan
christian jew
all in one great procession
marching
toward a rainbow land he said that a
hundred years ago
that ought to be taught
if we're going to overcome
the madness we're going through in this
in this country we need to know white
people in this country going back to
abigail adams
who really were in favor
of the liberation of black people we
need no need to know black people like
harry tubman and frederick douglass etc
again my facts may not be right on the
money but a couple of weeks ago
president clinton stood in front of the
anderson cottage out here at the old
soldiers home 750 thousand dollars to
repair it
i think he mentioned that it was in this
cottage that abraham lincoln wrote a lot
of the emancipation proclamation
implying that's very positive very good
i kind of connect that to want to ask
you whether
is bill clinton
as i said several years ago the first
black american president
give me two seconds i hope that we come
to this
first point
the dedication of this cottage
in in the summer
and i read
newspapers
all across this country
almost all of them wrong
almost all of them
totally wrong
the big
american newspaper the paper of record
said
that it was in the soldiers home where
that abraham lincoln drafted the
emancipation proclamation he did no such
thing did no such thing another major
american newspaper and just let me read
this i i brought it to read i won't name
the newspaper
so it was at the cottage
in 1862 that lincoln wrote the final
draft of the emancipation proclamation
issued january 1st 1863 the proclamation
freed slaves in confederate territory
controlled by union forces now there are
about five sentences here sentences here
and there's six major errors in the
justice fives this is a major american
newspaper in the first place place
what he he did not write
the second draft of the emancipation
proclamation that card is what he wrote
there and he didn't write it he wrote he
made notes there for the preliminary
proclamation
now now this is 2000
american media don't know the difference
between the preliminary proclamation and
emancipation proclamation
the other point
was that
document was issued on september 22 1862
the emancipation proclamation was
drafted in the white house on december
the 31st
1862 but i call your attention to this
sentence in a major newspaper
which said the proclamation freed slaves
in confederate territory controlled by
union forces it did the precise opposite
lincoln
[Music]
freed slaves in confederate territory
controlled by confederate troops
he left them in slavery
in confederate territory controlled by
union forces so
what about the other half of that bill
clinton
i i think his appointment policy is
it's been extraordinary
and it's an indication of
of what
we should expect from a president and
points in the direction
that we ought to go in terms of trying
to create a rainbow nation
lincoln was not going in that direction
at all
and uh again here's an indication of a
direction we need to go in
in order to create
the rainbow nation that that was dreamed
that has never been lived
but now he's you know he was part of
that symbol of
endorsing the abraham lincoln thing and
the whole
you know standing from the cottage and
that doesn't bother you
i mean
we're is there i mean all these
presidents both sides all say
great things about abraham lincoln but
you're basically saying it's all a lie
i'm saying
fact fact fact all the major newspapers
in america i can name them
said that he wrote the draft of the
declaration i mean of the emancipation
proclamation that god he did not do it
and this indicates one to me and i come
back to your question
that the misinterpretation and
misunderstanding of lincoln on this
issue has reached the level of a
national scandal
when all of the newspapers
put out this misinformation my second
second point
it doesn't bother me
even scholars it doesn't bother me
500 000 phds
swearing that lincoln wrote
the emancipation proclamation and that
in that thing will not change the fact
that he did not do it
the facts
are against the theory and it's the duty
of all
americans to
begin now to deal with the facts our
guest has been larone bennett jr this is
what the book looks like forced in the
glory abraham lincoln's white dream
thank you very much thank you delighted
to be here
[Music]
oh
for a transcript of this book notes call
1-800-777
text
for a video copy call
1-877 on c-span to read the first
chapter of many books featured on book
notes visit us on the world wide web at
booknotes.org
[Music]
next week on booknotes our guest is alan
murray author of the wealth of choices
how